bonjour justin bio merci d'accepter
notre invitation avant de vous poser la
première question je vous propose de
voir ce qu'a dit ce matin philippe
laurent le secrétaire général de
l'association des maires de france
nous pensons et nous sommes nombreux à
penser cela que ces commerces de
proximité doivent continuer à pouvoir
vivre et le livre est un produit
culturel de première nécessité avec
cette déclaration donc l'association des
maires de france les maires tous bords
confondus puisque par exemple on vient
de voir sur notre antenne tout à l'heure
louis aliot mais rennes ii perpignan
les maires se rebelle donc des avis de
l'exécutif pour soutenir leurs petits
commerces
oui voilà on va parler d'une rébellion
alors après peu importe le terme qu'on
utilise
je pense qu'il ya une volonté affirmée
des élus de faire face à ce qu'on
qualifie de totalement inéquitable et
d'injuste donc là on est face à un souci
de justice sociale et on ne veut pas
assister à un combat de david contre
goliath en restant inerte et c'est pour
ça que cet arrêté a été pris dans un but
premier qui était d'interpeller les
décideurs nationaux et c'est ce qui a
été fait ce qui a été fait puisque déjà
on voit que certaines mesures sont
d'ores et déjà prises
et voilà c'est quand même c'est quand
même très important que les petits
commerces puissent continuer d'ouvrir
leurs portes
on sait qu'ils respectent les gestes
barrière avec minutie et on ne comprends
absolument pas pourquoi on autorise des
grandes surfaces avec des foultitudes de
personnes dans les rayons et pas
quelques personnes une poignée de
personnes dans des commerces qui
respecte tous les gestes barrière on est
vraiment sur une mesure qui est
totalement inefficace et surtout très
injuste et avec votre arrêté es ce que
vous avez le sentiment d'être dans
l'illégalité et bien sûr alors j'ai pas
le sentiment d'être dans l'illégalité
j'ai l'impression de faire ce qui est
juste après effectivement cet arrêté est
illégal puisqu'il ne respecte pas le
décret qui est sorti la semaine dernière
mais après entre ce qui est légal et ce
qui est juste parfois il faut oser
prendre des risques je sais que certains
maires ont eu le courage de prendre cet
arrêté qui de toute façon va être
retoqué par la préfecture c'est le cas
de deux side mais en tout cas il était
nécessaire
que les maires se rebelle entre
guillemets puisque on ne parle pas de
rébellion
on parle encore d'un acte de justice
sociale et pourront il était évident de
prendre cet arrêté pour sauver nos
commerces
nous sommes dans des villes très
fragilisées ou les centres bourgs sont
fragilisés il était essentiel d'agir
justement vous le dites en les
centres-villes fragiliser certains
annoncent même la mort des petits
commerces pourtant il ya beaucoup
d'autres qui ont été annoncées par le
gouvernement ces derniers jours n'ont
alors effectivement il ya des aides mais
si vous voulez les critères sont
tellement sont tellement spécifiques
sont tellement restrictif que tout un
tas de commerce ne vont pas pouvoir en
bénéficier
on l'a vu lors de la première vague et
ce sera exactement le même cas lors de
la seconde vague
ce qui est très dangereux aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on approche on approche des
fêtes de noël et ce qui va se passer
dans des petites villes comme de 6
c'est une ville centre une ville de 5000
habitants les gens ne peuvent plus
consommer dans leurs commerces de
proximité ils ne peuvent pas faire des
distances pour aller consommer dans
d'autres commerces à 30 ou 40 kilos mais
est ce qui va se passer c'est qu'on va
avoir une surconsommation qui va se
diriger sur les plateformes internet
et quand on va arriver à la sortie de se
re confinement les gens ont déjà des
points c'est ce qu'ils avaient prévu de
dépenser et des petits commerces vont
être asphyxiées et je suis certaine
malheureusement qu'on va assister à un
drame et à un crash économique et social
qui n'est pas à mon sens suffisamment
anticipé et quand bruno le maire évoque
la nécessité de passer à la
digitalisation pour justement ces petits
commerces
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire évidemment
qu'il faut passer à la digitalisation
sauf que là encore ça nécessite des
soutiens des aides et puis on a besoin
de temps pour mettre en place et outils
créer des plateformes du commerce
on sait que c'est c'est sûr c'est sûr
c'est sur quoi pardon on entend et on va
devoir mettre en place de tels outils
mais là encore ça va pas se faire demain
il va falloir quelques semaines quelques
mois pour partir sur une digitalisation
est effectivement là on les commerces
sont vraiment au pied du mur et je ne
comprends vraiment pas qu'elle est
l'optique de ce gouvernement de venir
fermer ces petits commerces je ne
comprends pas sur notre antenne louis
aliot maire de perpignan mairie à rennes
ii perpignan a parlé de manque
d'anticipation d'impréparation du
gouvernement à vous entendre c'est
également ce que ce que vous dites mais
vous qu'est ce que vous auriez fait on a
l'impression que peu importe les
décisions dans l'impression qu'il ya
toujours des critiques non c'est quoi
c'est la politique politicienne à la
française même en période de pandémie il
y aura toujours des critiques
alors moi je ne suis pas sûr une
critique permanente de ce que fait le
gouvernement puisque je comprends qu'il
est difficile de concilier à la fois
d'éviter à tout prix un crash sanitaires
voilà le gouvernement là aussi ne peut
pas toujours tout anticipé puisque on
n'a pas de visibilité sur la propagation
de ce virus
mais de l'autre effectivement il faut
contenir au maximum le crash économique
et social je comprends ce qu'ils
essayent de faire le gouvernement
je comprends les mesures de semis
confinement qui ont été mises en oeuvre
mais malheureusement ces mesures restent
véritablement injuste alors soit il
fallait confiné plus fermement et
prendre des mesures qui soient
équitables envers tous les concitoyens
mais là on se retrouve sur des 2000
mesures qui sont malheureusement quelque
peu inéquitable et qu'il suffit
d'ajuster voilà alors après blâmer
gouvernement je dirais que oui c'est
facile quand on n'est pas au pouvoir
c'est facile de le faire après
effectivement je pense que on n'a pas
suffisamment de recul c'est une crise
sans précédent
et je pense aussi qu'il faut quand même
faire preuve de compréhension mais on
doit aussi au niveau du tissu local
remonter à des exécutifs des décisions
qui pouvaient qui pourraient être prises
de façon incohérente et c'est ce que
j'ai essayé de faire avec cet arrêté
le message est passé et merci justin
guillou d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes maire
decize dans la nièvre mr affilié au
parti socialiste